on nous annonce 300 emplois pour le
fonctionnement en grande partie des
contrats à durée indéterminée de 220
emplois à temps plein dont à côté d'eux
des temps plein des temps partiels dont
un grand nombre
quand on nous a vanté qu'il répondrait
aux besoins des agriculteurs en
difficulté qui seront des emplois
environ 3 de ménage à environ 300 euros
par semaine
donc ça je vais t'en prie ciel 300 euros
par mois bien autant à moi parce que
neuf heures par semaine il faut voir
dans quelle misère doit être le monde
agricole pour que on vante le fait que
des épouses d'agriculteurs qui sont
aujourd'hui dans difficultés vont enfin
pouvoir mettre la tête sous l'eau au
dehors de recherche fait un complément
de revenus pendant flamand oui mais
enfin moi je pense que des syndicats
agricoles que monde à l'école devrait
avoir beaucoup plus d'ambition que ça et
viser autre chose que d'aller simplement
faire le ménage
la fonte rapide être en fait circuler la
parole moi j'ai jamais entendu la
présentation des emplois suter phares
comme étant la solution pour les députés
du coup à la fois pour les épouses
d'agriculteurs non c'est quand même on
est sur deux zones notamment sur le banc
ce fourre-tout à la zone bourgogne où
l'on est dans une zone où mes collègues
politiques le savent mieux que moi le
taux de chômage est quand même autour
des 12 % je pense que même un emploi à
temps partiel pour quelqu'un qui au
chômage qui était victime d'un
licenciement économique d'une entreprise
ne serait-ce que financièrement mais
même socialement c'est quand même
quelque chose de de biens est important
et je pense que vu la situation dans
laquelle se trouve le pays en termes
d'emploi et de chômage
il faut savoir faire feu de tout bois et
il ya un moment donné il faut savoir
aussi saisir les opportunités qui
s'offrent m